guten abend aus berlin bekommt felix
runde die ganze welt sucht emh 370 wo
ist die boeing die seit zehn tagen wie
vom erdboden verschluckt ist es ist wohl
das mysteriöse verschwinden eines
fliegers in der geschichte der luftfahrt
ein riesenflugzeug in dem 239 menschen
saßen einfach weg ein horror für die
angehörigen und ein rätsel für experten
wir wollen hier in der phoenix runde
jetzt keine verschwörungstheorien
bedienen
aber die fakten die es zu dem fall gibt
diskutieren und versuchen die vielen
offenen fragen zu beantworten und auch
das ganze system fliegen über
sicherheitskontrollen ausbildung der
flug und so weiter diskutieren mit
luftfahrtexperten notfallseelsorger und
flugkapitän zuerst blicken wir aber mal
gemeinsam auf den letzten
informationsstand zu emh 370 norbert
lübbers berichtet die nerven liegen
blank bei den angehörigen der
chinesischen passagiere sagt uns endlich
die wahrheit rufen sie denn sie wollen
sich nicht länger vertrösten lassen und
drohen mit hungerstreik von der
regierung in malaysia fordern sie mehr
anstrengungen
uns geht es hier um jede sekunde
unsere familien sind kurz vor dem
zusammenbrechen die jungen unter und
vertragen den druck aber die älteren
sind am ende 26 länder beteiligen sich
nun in der suche nach der vermissten
boeing
doch das gebiet ist riesig es reicht vom
indischen ozean bis nach zentralasien
maschine könnte über wasser aber auch
auf dem festland verschollen seien
china startete eine suchaktion im
äußersten westen des landes
zusätzlich sollen 21 satelliten
eingesetzt werden
das aussenministerium kritisiert seit
tagen das krisen-management der malaysia
und spricht von chaotischen zuständen
sie haben die regierung und auch die
fluggesellschaft aufgefordert ehrlich
und aufrichtig auf die bedürfnisse der
angehörigen zu reagieren
doch antworten gibt es in malaysia nicht
die ermittlungen gehen in alle
richtungen sabotage entführung terrorakt
im moment scheint alles möglich selbst
der suizid eines der piloten
ob es dafür ein motiv gab das soll nun
geklärt werden
ja viele offene fragen wir wollen
versuchen ein wenig licht ins dunkel zu
bringen wer wo wie warum das rätsel um
flug lh 370 dass es unser thema heute
und hier sind meine gäste jörg handwerg
flugkapitän bei der lufthansa und der
pilotenvereinigung cockpit engagiert
welche voraussetzungen piloten
mitbringen müssen und wie welche technik
in einem flugzeug funktioniert das kann
er uns gleich sagen guten abend heinrich
großbongardt luftfahrt experte geht
davon aus dass die maschine wohl
irgendwann gefunden wird wie lange so
etwas dauern könnte
dazu gleich mehr von ihm bekommen auch
an sie justus münster notfallseelsorger
an den berliner flughäfen er kümmert
sich um angehörige in extremsituationen
nach einem flugzeugunglück über den
richtigen umgang mit ihnen kann er uns
gleich was erzählen guten abend und
rainer wewering freier journalist und
mitglied im luftfahrt presse club er
verfolgt den flug emh 370 seit seinem
verschwinden und ebenso die teilweise
weit reichenden spekulationen rund um
das verschwinden dieses flugzeuges herr
du ring kann es passieren dass
tatsächlich niemals auch nur ein stück
oder irgend etwas von dieser maschine
gefunden werden wird
es wird im laufe der zeit war
wahrscheinlicher diese möglichkeit denn
irgendwann selbst wenn sie ins meer
gestürzt sein sollte werden alle trümmer
versunken sein und dann wird man kaum
noch eine spur entdecken können der
großbäcker sie haben gesagt
möglicherweise wird man die maschine
irgendwann finden was macht sie da so
sicher oder wie könnte man sie findet
ich bin da gar nicht mehr so sicher weil
je größer der kreis der unsicherheit
wird größer der raum wird in denen sie
möglicherweise verschwunden ist
das willinger wie die wahrscheinlichkeit
man hat vor jahren de france hierfür
liegen
die maschine die im südatlantik
abgestürzt ist die hat man auch gefunden
aber das suchgebiet da war verglichen
mit heute sehr sehr viel kleiner
das ist jetzt man sucht eine fläche ab
die um den faktor 100 oder 1000 sogar
größer ist ja wir sprechen von einem
suchgebiet 77 millionen quadratkilometer
australien ist ein bisschen kleiner also
fast so groß wie australien oder sogar
größer und allein das suchgebiet über
dem wasser das sind 600.000
quadratkilometer das ist unvorstellbar
kann man da ein flugzeug finden was zwar
eigentlich groß ist aber verhältnismäßig
dann doch klein
man kann kein flugzeug finden sondern
ruft wonach man sucht sind vielleicht
koffer vielleicht gepäck container
vielleicht drei vier meter große stücke
der verkleidung des flugzeuges die
abgerissen sind die vielleicht noch
schwimmen das ist das wonach man sucht
und das ist beschreibt glaube ich auch
wie schwierig das ist etwas zu finden
wie gering die wahrscheinlichkeit ist
herr beck sie sind pilot sie sind
tagtäglich in den lüften unterwegs das
ist natürlich jetzt eine
außergewöhnliche situation wir wissen
nicht wirklich was passiert sein könnte
geht man trotzdem als pilot gehen sie
mit diesem gefühl dass so was mal
passieren könnte in den flieger oder ist
das gar nicht so bewusst sein
es ist immer im bewusstsein dass was
passieren kann aber das ist er nicht
über dem auto fahren da steigt man auch
nicht jeden tag ein und denkt sich
gestern waren wieder fünf unfälle auf
der autobahn sondern man versucht halt
alles zu tun das ist da nicht zukommt
und die chancen stehen nicht so schlecht
ist fliegen ist eines der sichersten
verkehrsmittel überhaupt und von daher
angst hat man da nicht gleich auch gern
noch mal mit ihm darüber reden wie so
der alltag eines kloten überhaupt
aussieht denn herr münster das ist ja
nun ein extremer fall wir haben gerade
im film die menschen gesehen
es sind viele chinesen die nicht wissen
was mit ihren angehörigen passiert ist
die gedroht haben in hungerstreik zu
treten
wie kann den momentan geholfen werden
das ist eine ganz ganz schwierige
situation für die angehörigen diese
wartezeit diese zeit der unsicherheit
das haben wir auch damals gesehen nach
der air-france-maschine waren vier tage
wenn ich mich recht entsinne wo die
suche dauerte und in diesen vier tagen
sind die angehörigen getragen von der
hoffnung dass ihre liebsten gefunden
werden dass die maschine notgewassert
ist notgelandet
ist dass es überlebende einfach gibt und
diese hoffnung trägt die angehörigen
auch jetzt noch und das was man den aber
die angehörigen erwarten können ist
einfach eine gute informationspolitik
das was die angehörigen wollen ist
information information informationen
und selbst wenn es nichts neues gibt
dann wollen sie wenigstens das hören wie
schwierig ist es diese information zu
geben tatsächlich in so einem moment
wenn man so wenig weiß
ich glaube es gibt sicherlich darum dass
die sich ernst genommen fühlen in ihren
sorgen ihrer trauer in ihrer
unsicherheit ich glaube er ist gar nicht
so sehr die fakten sondern das wirklich
das gefühl zu vermitteln
da nimmt uns jemand ernst und wir sind
wichtig herr großbongardt wie kann denn
so eine maschine vom radar verschwinden
das war das erste was ich mich auch
gefragt hat wie kann die einfach weg
seien nun dass eine maschine vom radar
verschwindet ist alltag
denn über dem offenen meer gibt es keine
radabdeckung wenn man heute über den
atlantik fliegt in die usa dann ist
irgendwann westlich von irland oder
westlich von schottland ist schluss da
ist man ist das flugzeug nicht mehr
sichtbar
und da fliegen die flugzeuge halt auf
vorbestimmten wegen bevor sie dann
irgendwann wieder auf vor neufundland in
sichtweite des radars kommen und dann
wieder eingegliedert werden
die lange zeitspanne seien das sind
viele stunden das den fünf sechs sieben
stunden auch über dem pazifik ist so
etwas ganz normal
aber wenn das so normal ist es gibt
trotzdem geräte die dafür sorgen dass
ich irgendwie erkannt werden kann also
ist da wirklich keine möglichkeit ein
flugzeug zu ordnen den moment es gibt
keine geräte wir haben ja bord seit ich
zwei geräte
dabei aber dieses gerät hat nur
begrenzte reichweite und nach 370
kilometern spätestens ist dann schluss
mit dem empfang und dann verschwinden
wir vom radarschirm und auf diesen wegen
gibt es nur melde punkte an diesen melde
punkten melden wir uns eben sagen wir
sind in der höhe mit der
geschwindigkeiten der warten am nächsten
punkt dann und dann zu sein und wenn wir
da dann plötzlich verschwunden sein
sollten dann fängt man an und versucht
uns mal zu rufen über langwelle also ein
sehr schlechte kommunikationsmöglichkeit
aber wir sind nirgends bildlich erfasst
kann denn das militär rein theoretisch
gesehen solche maschinen orten wie beim
ozean ist auch nicht aber in dem
vorliegenden fall befand sich die
maschine eigentlich in der ersten zeit
immer im bereich von radarstationen und
da hatte das bringt er durchaus die
möglichkeit die maschine zu sehen wie
bisher dann später auch gehört haben
warum das dann so lange gedauert hat ist
bei das eingeräumt hat das ist eine der
vielen fragen die uns zu denken gibt und
der kontakt zum boden wenn ich das
richtig verstehe gut auf dem radar ist
die maschine möglicherweise über zwei
stunden nicht zu sehen weil es da kein
kontakt gibt man über wasser es hat man
ihn aber nicht die möglichkeit mit dem
piloten zu sprechen sie können auch
jederzeit quasi kontakt aufnehmen wie
gehe ich mal fort aus wir können
jederzeit kontakt aufnehmen es gibt im
prinzip zwei systeme dazu das eine ist
langwellen punkte ist sag ich mal von
der qualität her eher so steinzeitlich
also ganz schlechte qualität und da hört
man auch nicht die ganze zeit rein weil
das ist eine belastung das das hält man
nicht aus und wir haben den üblichen
kurzwellen sprech verkehr den wir hier
nutzen
der hat aber nur eine sehr geringe
reichweite und den können wir über
wasser dann nicht mehr nutzen
also wir sind nicht permanent in
verbindung mit der flugsicherung sondern
eben nur an diesen vorgegebene melde
punkten melden wir uns dann und
zwischendrin schalten wir den funk eben
aus was wird in einem notfall passieren
im notfall könnten wir natürlich diesen
funk nutzen und die flugsicherung
ansprechen und uns mitteilen
also die möglichkeit besteht zumindest
das
man sich irgendwie gehör verschaffen
kann wenn irgendwas passiert jetzt wird
immer wieder gesagt da wurde etwas
ausgeschaltet helfen sie mir erklären
sie mir was da möglicherweise
ausgeschaltet werden kann
es gibt einige automatische systeme in
einem flugzeug das eine ist der so
genannte transponder das ist ein
sekundärer radar das heißt mit dem radar
signal wird zurück eine information
übertragen an die bodenstationen aus der
sie die position der maschine die
flughöhe und so weiter entnehmen können
und das zweite das ist das system das in
bestimmten abständen automatisch
betriebsdaten überträgt via satellit das
wird von den flugzeugherstellern und von
den triebwerksherstellern erster linie
genutzt um die maschine zu überwachen um
frühzeitig irgendwelche störungen zu
erkennen und diese beiden systeme die
können natürlich ausgeschaltet das ist
ja alles unglaublich technisch sie
kennen sich da gut mit aus als normal
flieger setzte ich mich ins flugzeug und
denk mir alle gut ausgebildet läuft
schon ich komme wahrscheinlich hoch und
auch wieder runter wie ist dann so der
alltag eines piloten wie sicher kann ich
mich dann fühlen an bord sie können sich
sehr sicher fühlen also fliegen ist ja
sehr sicher aber natürlich es gibt
nirgends 100 prozent auch nicht in der
fliegerei auch da passiert mal was wir
haben sehr sehr viele sicherheitsnetze
die sich ergänzen
aber im ungünstigsten fall kann es schon
mal dazu kommen dass etwas passiert in
diesem fall kann man ja nicht wissen ob
es ein technisches versagen war oder ob
da eine intention dahinter stand ob es
wirklich absichtlich zu vorfall gekommen
ist kann jemand so ins cockpit kommen so
normal nicht was heißt normal nicht also
unnormal eigentlich schon
es gibt keine 100-prozentige sicherheit
auch in dem fall gibt es die nicht und
wenn man natürlich weiß wie man es
anstellt dann kann man das schaffen also
auch piloten müssen unter umständen mal
auf die toilette gehen und dann geht die
tür auf und auch die kabinenbesatzung
muss immer mal wieder ins cockpit kommen
und da ist die tür ebenen moment lang
offen wie gut kennt sich eigentlich die
flugkörper so langstreckenflügen
das ist ganz unterschiedlich also in
großen unternehmen kennt man sich
eigentlich eher nicht es gibt einfach zu
viel personal das wird immer wieder neu
zusammen gestellt jeder hat seinen
individuellen dienstplan und daraus
ergibt sich dann das team
das heißt oftmals lernt man sich erst
direkt vor dem flug kennen was auch
spannend ist dass heute jemand gesagt
hat oder menschen gesagt haben auf den
malediven wir haben da ein tief
fliegendes flugzeug gesehen das war rot
weiß wir haben das auch angegeben es hat
aber keinen interessiert ist das alltag
dass solche meldungen gibt und das wird
im zweifel gar nicht ernst genommen ich
glaube das ist ein teil des großen
informationschaos um diesen vorfall
denn es ist ja vom ersten tage an
unglaublich schwer gewesen
herauszufinden was sind denn eigentlich
echte informationen was stimmt was
stimmt nicht was sind vermutungen was
sind behauptungen und das hat man im
übrigen eigentlich bei jedem größeren
flugzeugabsturz dass irgend jemand
irgendwas gesehen hat das irgendwie mal
ein flugzeug ein brennen oder trudeln
sehen oder was auch immer
das ist eigentlich so standard und es
ist in den allermeisten fällen nichts
dran
was ist der netz möglicherweise das
wahrscheinlichste was mit dieser
maschine passiert sein könnte spricht
mehr dafür dass es abgestürzt ist
irgendwann müsste ja auch mal der sprit
ausgeben ganz platt gesagt sicher muss
und wann der sprit aller gewesen sein
und wenn die maschine dann nicht
gelandet war dann dann ist sie
zwangsläufig abgestürzt aber man weiß es
nicht es gibt so viele widersprüchliche
informationen und man hat auch den
eindruck dass nicht alle tatsächlich
vorliegenden informationen bereits
bisher bekannt gegeben worden sind dass
man
das wirklich nicht sein kann also es
besteht immer noch die geringe
möglichkeit dass sie tatsächlich
irgendwo gelandet ist
dann gibt es aber auch keine erklärung
dafür warum man dann nichts mehr gehört
hat dann bei einer einführung hätten die
entführer ja sicherlich irgendeine
absicht diese kulturen wollen und wenn
sie abgestürzt ist ja dann gibt es einen
sehr weiten bereich wo sie sein könnte
wie gewöhnlich ist es in so einem fall
dass so viele auch mit eingebunden sind
da sind natürlich teilweise auch
informationslecks würde ich mal sagen
wenn so viele verschiedene dienste an
einer geschichte dran sind
oder ist das normal es ist natürlich in
diesem fall wegen der unheimlichen größe
des gebietes das geht ja vor der
westküste australiens bis nach keiner
star sind so viele staaten beteiligt
dass das natürlich auch zum informations
wirrwarr beiträgt aber konzentriert ist
und tatsächlich alles bei dem
malaysischen behörden die darauf
bestehen weiterhin die oberaufsicht zu
haben
das völkerrecht ich auch sicher richtig
ist aber die sich auch ein bisschen
zurückhaltend was jetzt ausländische
unterstützung betrifft wir wollen
nochmal uns den angehörigen widmen sie
haben eben schon gesagt dass es eben
eine extremsituation er versuchen sie in
dem moment zu helfen wie geht denn so
eine maschinerie los wenn sie hören da
kommt der anruf berlin flughafen gott
bewahre da ist was passiert und sie
werden angerufen was passiert dann
das muss er noch nicht mal sein dass
hier in berlin am flughafen tatsächlich
etwas passiert ist sondern bis 1996
hatten nach dem absturz der bürgernäher
maschine vor der dominikanischen
republik und die abholen denn sich in
schönefeld versammelt haben würden wir
von der flughafengesellschaft oder der
berliner polizei oder der feuerwehr
alarmiert werden und würden dann mit die
notfallseelsorge kräften die wir haben
nur für sie sorge und krisenintervention
zum flughafen fahren und einfach schauen
wo abholen tatsächlich sind würden sie
versuchen so wie das hier ja auch
geschehen ist in peking sie so ein
bisschen zu separieren sie sozusagen in
einen geschützten raum zu bringen und
dann einfach schauen welches angebot wir
machen passt
die menschen dann in dieser situation
brauchen das eine ist natürlich dass sie
sich ernst genommen fühlen über
informationen gebündelte informationen
vielleicht übernimmt das an diesem fall
sogar die airline weil das sozusagen die
auch die menschen erwarten von der
airline dass sie von ihnen die
informationen bekommen und das eben auch
aus erster hand tatsächlich von den
vertretern der leyen bekommen und als
notfallseelsorger sind wir dann da und
schauen einfach wie wir unterstützend
tätig werden können indem wir vielleicht
einfach zusammen schweigen
indem wir aushalten in dem wir menschen
das gespräch anbieten
wichtig ist es in so einem fall wo die
menschen sich natürlich noch mal
hoffnung machen
die hoffnung stirbt zuletzt es ist
tatsächlich so dass man denkt vielleicht
ist die maschine irgendwo gelandet und
wir hören irgendwann was das noch mal
eine schwierigere situation
das erschwert den ganzen prozess
natürlich unglaublich das vermissen
sozusagen nicht genau wissen was das
schicksal ihrer angehörigen
tatsächlich ist was mit ihren
angehörigen ist wie die letzten stunden
minuten ihre angehörigen aus gesehen
haben für die ist es noch mal
unglaublich schwerer das auch nur
beginnen zu können zu begreifen was er
tatsächlich passiert ist und in dieser
situation ist es natürlich gut wenn sie
eben hilfe bekommen und unterstützung
bekommen
wie gehen sie da auch grad mit
angehörigen von crewmitgliedern oben das
stelle ich mir auch noch mal schwierig
vor die vielleicht doch auch mit dieser
angst leben dass da was passieren könnte
wie gehen sie damit um
wir würden schon also in dem fall würde
man versuchen zum beispiel auch
angehörige von crewmitgliedern von
vielleicht den angehörigen der
passagiere zu trennen und einfach zu
schauen dass da auch nicht untereinander
so zu sagen vielleicht aggressionen auch
unterwegs sind das muss man einfach
gucken und von fall zu fall tatsächlich
an der stelle entscheiden aber natürlich
ist es für für die angehörigen der crone
mitglieder auch sehr sehr schwierig an
dieser situation damit umzugehen weil
sie vor der selben situation stehen mit
derselben situation konfrontiert sind
dass sie einen lieben menschen
wahrscheinlich verloren haben und dieses
wahrscheinlich ist das was die menschen
umtreibt
werden sie auf solche situationen
vorbereitet gibt's da trainings also was
glaube ich kann man nicht wirklich
trainieren
ich weiß auch nicht wie man das
trainieren sollte dem verlust eines
geliebten menschen
das ist eine lebenserfahrung die man
sicherlich irgendwann macht einfach
aufgrund der familie die man hat aber es
ging habe ich tut mir leid etwas falsch
ausgedrückt eigentlich auch um ein
training um sie sozusagen für
extremsituationen die sie möglicherweise
an bord erleben könnten vorzubereiten
in gewisser weise ja also solche dinge
werden schon mal angesprochen und es ist
natürlich bewusst wenn wir mit mehreren
hundert menschen durch die gegend
fliegen das dann immer mal was passieren
kann und da gibt es ja auch mal
todesfälle unter den passagieren und das
ist für uns natürlich als piloten
erstmal natürlich man muss das verdauen
auf der anderen seite sind wir in der
situation natürlich auch sehr gefragt
was was das handling angeht also wo
befinden wir uns denn wo können wir denn
jetzt hin was können wir noch tun
manchmal geht es menschen die schlecht
und wir müssen möglichst schnell runter
also das sind operationelle dinge die
wir natürlich auch lernen und mit denen
wir uns auseinandersetzen und dann setzt
man sich auch automatisch natürlich mit
dem schicksal der menschen auseinander
vielleicht interessant zu wissen dass
fluggesellschaften flughäfen die alle
verfügen über krisenpläne wir alle haben
in der schublade eine genaue planung was
zu tun ist was passiert wie informiere
ich die angehörigen wie informiere ich
die mitarbeiter ihre kollegen werden in
einem solchen fall ja genauso betroffen
wer ist für was verantwortlich da gibt
es eine eine sehr komplexe maschinerie
bei den fluggesellschaften wie auch bei
den bei den flughäfen jeder
möglicherweise betroffen sind die bei
uns dafür sorgen dass solche dinge trotz
einer unvermeidlich chaotischen
situation doch geordnet ablaufen ist als
internationaler standard
das ist internationaler standard da gibt
es von der von der iata von der
weltluftfahrtorganisation gibt es muster
krisenpläne das krisen trainings sie den
airlines wie die flughäfen angeboten
werden hat
als industrie auch begriffen wie wichtig
das ist für solche fälle vorzusorgen
jetzt gibt es den verdacht oder die
spekulation dass der pilot
möglicherweise suizid begangen haben
könnte dass der pilot möglicherweise
dahinter stecken könnte oder der
co-pilot wie werden piloten eigentlich
durchgecheckt es gibt auch immer wieder
gesundheitsprüfung soweit ich weiß was
wird so mit einem piloten gemacht
es gibt schon gesundheitsprüfung aber da
wird keine psychische evaluation
vorgenommen man wird da nicht den
psychologen irgendwie vorgestellt in dem
sinne nicht bitter nicht mehr guck
tiefdruck hätte jemand aus wie geht es
jemanden da hat ja eine große
verantwortung
sie haben verantwortung ist richtig aber
zum einen wenn es einem psychisch nicht
gut geht dann ist es auch die
eigenverantwortung natürlich des
betroffenen
dass er sich dann auch mal meldet dass
er sich vielleicht irgendwo in der hilfe
zuwendet andererseits wir sie stehen ja
täglich im druck und dann merkt man ja
schon auch bei den simulator
überprüfungen oder druck natürlich
extrem zugespitzt wird ob jemand die
leistung bringen kann oder nicht
aber es ist auch eigentlich in dem
jetzigen stadium ist es sage ich mal
gerade wenn wir bei den betroffenen sind
aus meiner sicht auch völlig
unverantwortlich dass man hier jetzt
jegliche spekulationen die haben
irgendwie ein feld über die piloten
durch die presse treibt denn man sollte
man an die angehörigen denken die ja
sowieso schon diesen verlust zu
verkraften haben und die werden jetzt
auch noch damit belastet dass ihre
partner oder angehörigen in verruf
gebracht werden obwohl es überhaupt
keine beweise dafür gibt nicht mal ernst
zu nehmende hinweise dafür gibt und das
halten wir ehrlich gesagt für ziemlich
unverantwortlich und natürlich als pilot
ist das dann in dem moment fühlt man
sich da von selbst unter generalverdacht
gestellt aber es muss in alle richtungen
ermittelt werden ist sicher alle
richtungen ermittelt werden in diesem
fall auch für relativ unwahrscheinlich
halte dann wenn ein pilot selbstmord
begehen möchte den mann sein flugzeug
zum absturz bringt was wir ja leider
auch schon in der vergangenheit hatten
dann wird er das in dem geeigneten
moment tun wenn der zweite pilot
vielleicht gerade auf der toilette ist
oder so der darsteller handeln kann
aber der wird ja nicht noch ein paar
stunden durch die gegend fliegen also
das passt überhaupt nicht passt nicht
zusammen das typischerweise noch sieben
stunden flugzeit bildes da sein könnten
dass das widerspricht sich wie konnte
man das eigentlich so genau herausfinden
diese maschine sind das die punkte die
sie vorhin erwähnten die maschine ist
dann irgendwo noch mal geortet worden
auch das ist ja eine information die man
mit äußerster vorsicht bewerten muss
also es gibt die information eines
satellitenbetreibers dass er signale
dieses aka systems empfangen hat dieses
systems an bord das technische daten
überträgt das also versucht hat
verbindung mit dem satelliten
aufzunehmen
ob das wirklich dieses flugzeug war ist
im augenblick vollkommen ungeklärt da
steht völlig dahin kann man gar nicht so
genau kann man gar nicht so genau sagen
ob das flugzeug tatsächlich von dem
moment an wo es zuletzt gesehen wurde
oder vermutlich gesehen wurde
möglicherweise muss ja ganz vorsichtig
sein
überhaupt noch genug treibstoff hatte
dafür muss man auch sehen denn der flug
von kuala lumpur nach peking sind sechs
stunden ziemlich genau
und da wird auch für sechs stunden plus
die reserve plus das was man auch
braucht uns einen ausweichflughafen zu
kommen getankt aber nicht mehr etwas
etwas über sieben vielleicht also in
tripolis hätten 200 er hat eine
reichweite von 14.500 kilometern
die waren nicht voll getankt das ist
auch diese sieben stunden sind eine
reine spekulation
da ist überhaupt nichts verifiziert das
ist das besondere an diesem fall das ist
eigentlich abgesehen davon von der
tatsache der flieger ist irgendwo vom
flugsicherungs radar verschwunden
da ist das zuletzt positiv identifiziert
worden
das ist die einzige information an die
man sich wirklich halten kann
alles andere was draußen ist ist ja
informations rauschen schwer zu bewerten
schwer einzuordnen nicht verifiziert
aber ich frage mich tatsächlich im jahr
2014 wo man so ziemlich alles orten kann
wie über nsa und ich weiß nicht was
diskutieren und uns auch in teilweise
ärgern wie das wirklich sein kann dass
das es kein abhängiges system gibt kein
system um ein flieger zu finden um ein
flieger irgendwie immer orten zu können
man darf nie vergessen dieser fall ist
außergewöhnlich bindet sich die
geschichte der luftfahrt angucken das
letzte mal dass ein verkehrsflugzeug
wirklich verschwunden ist dauerhaft
verschwunden ist war 1979 eine
frachtmaschine von japan airlines über
den pazifik das war seit den 60er jahren
das einzige verkehrsflugzeug das
wirklich verschwunden ist dass man auch
nie wieder gefunden hat
alles andere in allen anderen fällen hat
man abstürze gehabt und hat dann also
spätestens nach drei tagen oder vier
tage wie im fall der air france maschine
dann auch das flugzeug die absturzstelle
finden können lässt sich so ein flugzeug
fernsteuern
wenn es entsprechend ausgestattet wäre
sowie eine drohne dann würde das gehen
ein normales verkehrsflugzeug ist damit
nicht ausgestattet und lässt sich also
nicht vom boden aus veranstalter also
ich könnte mich nicht in die system
einklinken
wenn ich wollte hier sein computersystem
das ding das ginge nicht bedrohen würde
das gehen sie wählen die automatisch
gesteuert dafür gebaut
es gab jetzt diese spekulation kommen ja
weil es auf einem sicherheits kongress
hat ein mensch mal ein versuch gemacht
so ein trocken versuch mit original
rechnern aus einem flugzeug und konnte
dort gewisse manipulationen eben
vornehmen in diesem test aufbau
sozusagen
hat halt er wollte damit nur darauf
hinweisen dass flugzeuge heute nicht
ausreichend abgesichert sind und dass
man da eben aufpassen muss aber die
vorstellung dass eine mit seinem handy
hier das flugzeug manipulieren kann und
der pilot da oben sitzt und nichts mehr
machen kann die ist völlig unsinnig wie
funktioniert da mein handy eigentlich an
bord es wird ja immer gesagt bloß
ausschalten die ganzen flieger noch
nicht mal der flug modus ist oft in
ordnung bitte ganz ausschalten
ist das überhaupt noch nötig nun das
handy funktioniert auch nur über land
wenn überhaupt die gsm netze reichen
auch nur 20 30 kilometer über wasser und
dann ist schluss
auch das ist ultrakurzwelle dann dazu
noch durch die leistung des handys durch
die sendeleistung mit sehr geringer
reichweite da passiert gar nichts und
was man nicht vergessen darf zum thema
fernsteuerung die drohnen verfügen über
eine ziemlich leistungsfähige
satellitenantenne die milch in der lage
dafür sorgt dass diese drohne die
irgendwo über jenem oder afghanistan
ansonsten unterwegs ist über satellit
ständig in verbindung steht mit
demjenigen der sie irgendwo in den usa
steuert da ist ein ständiger datenfluss
und das ist erfordert auch einiges an an
bandbreite an übertragungskapazität so
etwas gibt es in einem verkehrsflugzeug
ist das nicht geben nein das wird es
nicht warum weil diese technik einfach
aber ist sie nicht ausgereift so wenn
man sieht wie viele drohnen heute
abstürzen und wieviel problem ist damit
gibt das wäre für die zivilluftfahrt
völlig inakzeptabel zum zweiten ist es
überhaupt nicht notwendig wir haben dort
piloten an bord die können das flugzeug
zuverlässig steuern und wir brauchen
keine fernsteuerung am boden
die satellitenkapazitäten die man dafür
beleuchtung weltweit alle flugzeuge mit
solch einem system auszustatten
die gibt es nicht also das wäre ein
wahnsinniger aufwand und das sind
letzten endes ja auch alles kosten die
mit fast keinem nutzen verbunden sind
und die müssen ja irgendwann
irgendjemand getragen werden letzten
endes von passagieren
sie haben eben kurz noch mal um bei dem
handy zu bleiben gesagt doch da kann
eigentlich nichts passieren also könnte
ich weinte
rich gesehen ruhig mein handy an bord an
lassen da gibt es ja nun auch in der
europäischen union mittlerweile
verschiedene meinung dass gesagt wird
das schadet eigentlich nicht also im
flugmodus dürfen sie ist ja inzwischen
das ist zugelassen worden aber es darf
kein gerät an bord senden oder empfangen
weil wir ja eine vielzahl von antennen
haben die unter umständen wenn eben
genügend handys an sind dann könnte es
zu einer beeinflussung kommen man weiß
es nicht 100 prozent wie sich auswirkt
deswegen sagt man aus sicherheitsgründen
lasst die handys aus spaß macht sowieso
keinen sinn
außerdem stört es auch die netzbetreiber
denn die stürzen da stürzen regelmäßig
die kontaktpunkte diese die
empfangsstationen am boden ab wenn man
damit sehr hoher geschwindigkeit darüber
fliegt weil die gar nicht so schnell
umschalten können aber im notfall könnte
ich ja telefonieren es gab auch
angehörige die gesagt haben ich habe
angerufen es hat noch geklingelt
ist das auch wieder eben die hoffnung
die man hat natürlich ist es die
hoffnung die man auf jeden fall hat und
das ist die hoffnung die dann an der
stelle halte auch trägt aber wir sollten
uns dann halt auch für die angehörigen
führten die spekulationen ins kraut
schießen zu lassen natürlich kann man
sich darüber unterhalten sollte man ein
flugzeug ferne bedienbar machen oder
nicht nur dann hätte ihre frage
natürlich noch viel mehr sinn mussten
wir nicht angst auch davor haben dass
dieses flugzeug dann tatsächlich
übernommen werden kann
das heißt wir sollten wirklich schauen
was an gesicherter informationen ist
tatsächlich da und was an gesicherte
informationen kann man halt wirklich
weitergeben und das was ich sehe in den
letzten tagen einfach bemerkt habe und
was mir halt auch wirklich aufgefallen
ist ist dass verschiedene informationen
immer wieder nachträglich sozusagen
eingereicht wurden dann sagt das militär
man hat dann doch irgendwas gesehen oder
sozusagen gehört an der fünf tage erst
später nach dem verschwinden des fluges
und das wirft er fragezeichen auf und
darüber denke ich sollte man sich eher
noch mal und auch in der auswertung
sozusagen dieses ganzes unglücks noch
mal unterhalten als darüber ob man
flugzeuge tatsächlich fernbedienung
macht also nochmal eine bessere
strukturierung der behörde im notfall
das uns auf genau dass sie alle zusammen
arbeiten
die sollte besser funktionieren sollte
besser funktionieren
man hat schon den eindruck dass hier
immer nur stückchenweise informationen
herausgegeben werden und es weckt den
eindruck dass hier wirklich nicht ist ja
nicht alles gesagt worden ist was die
malaysischen könnte das liegen ist
natürlich regulationen aber warum legt
man sie warten nicht auf den tisch dass
das militär
insbesondere in diesen ländern ist von
natur aus aufgibt eines kämmerei fixiert
die sind natürlich die letzten die die
tür aufmachen und alle informationen auf
den tisch packen sondern da geht es um
dann geht es um macht da geht es um ist
immer wirklich auch struktur darum
selbstverständnis die fühlen sich eben
auch nicht als teil der
zivilgesellschaft und da ist kann ich
mir gut vorstellen dass überhaupt
innerhalb des militärs die frage ob ich
solche rader daten rausgeben überhaupt
zu analyse an die man an einen dritten
das allein das schon in vielen ländern
eine riesen hürde ist wir sind finde ich
jetzt auch gerade noch mal bei dem
sicherheitsaspekt also was kann fliegen
auch sicherer machen ferngesteuert
wollen wir nicht unbedingt sein wenn ich
versuche meinen deoroller irgendwie
durch die sicherheitskontrolle zu
kriegen scheitere ich kläglich daran das
wird mir abgenommen und weggeworfen
wir haben aber erfahren bei diesem flug
dass dort menschen an bord waren die
gestohlene pässe hatten
ob die was damit zu tun haben oder nicht
sei dahin gestellt wo nicht nach
jetzigem stand der dinge
aber wie kann es denn sein dass
tatsächlich menschen an bord gehen
können die überhaupt nicht die sind die
sie zu sein scheinen also in dem fall
ist ganz offensichtlich bei den
sicherheitskontrollen geschlampt worden
denn es gibt ja eine datenbank von
interpol
wo solche pässe erfasst werden und in
diesem fall waren sie auf fast bloß es
gibt nur sehr wenige länder die bei den
passagieren wirklich die daten
abgleichen mit der datenbank von
interpol bisher und in malaysia ist das
ganz offensichtlich nicht der fall
gewesen
deutschland dazu deutschland gehört hat
gegen deutschland wird das alltägliche
aber gut hilft mir im zweifel nicht bei
den vielen flugverkehr von danach da und
umsteigen und so weiter
wie wird abgeglichen man passiert immer
genommen und gescannt ist das abgleichen
das ist die automatische abfrage ist die
frage womit wird abgeglichen wird das
aber mit der malaysischen fahndungsliste
abgeglichen oder wird es mit der
internationalen fahndungsliste
abgeglichen und in dem fall
offensichtlich hat man die
internationalen daten nicht
berücksichtigt oder wird es überhaupt
abgeglichen und man darf aber nicht
vergessen das ist in einigen ländern ist
es einfach oder wird eine findet eine
sichtkontrolle statt
da schaut man halt sie der ausweis
irgendwie gefälscht aus oder sieht der
realistisch aus ist noch gültig passt
das bild und dann wird man durchgewunken
also man muss auch sehen dass natürlich
heute unmengen an menschen fliegen und
der aufwand die alle zu kontrollieren
ist halt sehr groß und nicht alle
betreiben den wie werden sie
kontrolliert als pilot wir werden auch
wenn wir durch eine eigene kontrolle
gehen dann werden wir auch auf ausweis
und sich kontrolliert aber wir
durchlaufen auch die
sicherheitskontrollen entweder wenn wir
auf sprengstoff untersucht oder wir
werden eben durch die üblichen
sicherheitskontrollen die auch
passagiere durch laufen geschickt
oftmals gehen wir sowieso an den
flughäfen durch die ganz normalen
kontrollen also überall im ausland haben
wir keine eigenen separaten kontrollen
da gehen wir durch die kontrollen der
passagiere im prinzip durch werden
manchmal vorbeigeschleust mit schneller
geht aber jetzt habe ich nämlich oft
gesehen der pilot dann ganz elegant dran
vorbei gehen
genau wir werden vorgezogen und kostümen
haben man muss natürlich ein ausweis
vorzeigen und da muss man sagen da
weisen wie auch immer darauf hin dass
die kontrollen so wie sie jetzt
stattfinden eigentlich uns nicht
sinnvoll sind
also es macht keinen sinn piloten auf
eine nagelschere zu kontrollieren oder
so was ich habe auch hier vermutlich
auch nicht ja da könnte man noch drüber
diskutieren aber ich habe von den achsen
im cockpit also ich brauche keinen
gefährlichen gegen ich brauche keinen
gefährlichen gegenstand ich kann auch
einfach warten bis mein kollege auf
toilette geht wie wir eben schon gehört
haben
und der kommt nie wieder eine
schusssichere tür also das ist einfach
unsinn was wir hier machen dass ist
blinder aktionismus der eben auf den
elften september zurückzuführen ist
eigentlich bräuchten wir eine sichere
identitätskontrolle hier haben wir nicht
unsere ausweis ist nicht
fälschungssicher aber würden sie das
auch auf die passagiere beziehen was ich
tatsächlich viele passagiere ärgern mit
denen er zum flüssigkeits vorschriften
die ich da nicht an bord nehmen darf
aber es können eben leute an bord gehen
von denen ich gar nicht weiß wer sie
sind sollte man es auf passagiere
ausweiten also sicherlich auch im
passagierbereich wäre es sinnvoller mehr
zu schauen wer geht denn da an bord was
hat er denn für den hintergrund aber ob
man das im gleichen umfang machen sollte
wie bei cruise das würden wir eher nicht
so sehen weil sie brauchen auch eine
gewisse zufalls kontrolle
gerade bei den passagieren müssen sie
unberechenbar bleiben wenn sie anfangen
system einzuführen sagen wir
kontrollieren keine flüssigkeiten mehr
dann werden sie dem nächsten problem
kriegen aber ob nun ist das problem
sicherlich ist es ja es ist ja hat ja
einen guten grund weshalb diese
beschränkung darin wenngleich diskutiert
wird das ganze ist aber auch in europa
wieder abzusprechen
aber grundsätzlich ist es natürlich so
dieses sicherheitssystem was ich habe in
der luftfahrt ist tief gestaffelt es
gibt mehrere mehrere geschichten durch
die jemand durch kommen muss und ob das
funktioniert insgesamt hängt natürlich
davon ab ob die menschen die am ende da
verantwortlich sind die kontrolle
durchführen
ob da jeder seinen job macht ob er das
ob er richtig ausgebildet ist ob die das
system die sicherheitssystem an dem
flughafen in dem land richtig
implementiert ist ob ausreichend
kontrollen stattfinden um auch immer
wieder zu überwachen zu kontrollieren
funktioniert das denn alles auch das
erfordert einen ziemlichen aufwand und
erfordert auch eine sehr gut
funktionierende verwaltung dahinter und
man muss realistischerweise sagen die
ist nicht in allen ländern dieser welt
so gut wie bei uns in europa oder in den
usa wie gewöhnlich ist dass das
passagiere an bord sind von denen man
eigentlich gar nicht wirklich was weiß
die möglicherweise gefälschte papiere
haben kann man schlecht beurteilen nicht
auffällt aber ich denke mal dass der
antrag doch ganz schön groß ist vor
allem auch innereuropäisch wenn ich bin
neulich geflogen nach wien da hat auch
einer irgendwas gefragt 9 wenn sie denn
wenn sie innerhalb der eu bzw
des schengen-raums fliegen da gibt es ja
keine kontrollen weil man sich darauf
verlässt dass die außengrenzen
ausreichend überwacht werden aber wer
einmal ist und der europäisch fliegt
dessen identität wird nicht mehr
überprüft ist sollten die kontrollen
strenger werden oder kann man dadurch
auch nicht wirklich was verhindern
man könnte durchaus schon ein bisschen
genauer gucken wer da an bord geht was
irgend jetzt hier innerhalb europas
gerade nicht mehr gemacht würde also
strengere kontrollen
es gibt in den letzten jahren wenig
anlass dazu und man muss ja immer sehen
wenn man sich an die unmittelbare zeit
nach dem 11 september erinnert wo ihr
auch eine gewisse sicherheitshysterie
war
man muss sich immer dafür hüten dass der
luftverkehr durch solche maßnahmen
stranguliert wird das ist ja unangenehm
für die passagiere
das macht man ja nicht gerne das kostet
zeit man verpasst seinen flieger die
zeit am flughafen wird unnötig lang und
wie gesagt es ist etwas selbst wenn man
weiß dass es für die eigene sicherheit
ist es ist einfach unangenehm und da
muss dann wirklich mit augenmaß zur
sache gehen und das tun was notwendig
ist aber nicht mehr
also bei ihnen hörte ich ein bisschen
raus konsequenzen ziehen aber eher in
die richtung dass die piloten nicht mehr
so stark kontrolliert werden also sollte
es jetzt mehr sicherheit geben oder
sollte man alles nochmal überdenken
sagen nicht wie sollen weniger
kontrolliert werden sondern sinnvolle
also die maßnahmen die überhaupt
generell bei den kontrollen die
angesetzt werden die müssen auch ihren
zweck erfüllen und nicht nur einfach
bremsen
und wenn ich halt völlig sinnlose
vorschriften habe die eigentlich nur den
luftverkehr schweren dann sind wir
dagegen und da gibt es leider heutzutage
so einige das geht da mehr um die
gefühlte sicherheit als um die wirklich
ist ich erhalte und bis zum wissen maß
kann man das wir betreiben aber wir sind
immer so einem punkt wo wir an der
oberen kante sind man fragt sich
tatsächlich jedes mal ich frage mich
warum muss ich die schuhe ausziehen
seitdem schuhbomber gibt es eben
besondere vorschriften die sagen wenn da
irgendwas pieps man muss ja nicht
grundsätzlich aus ziehen sondern
eigentlich wenn es klingelt wenn man
durch die sonne geht dann muss man sie
ausziehen weil es könnte ja irgendwas
drin versteckt sein
jetzt wissen wir tatsächlich wir haben
es immer wieder gesagt nicht was bei
diesem in diesem fall passiert ist war
an dieser maschine möglicherweise wieder
auftaucht ob sie jemals gefunden wird
was meinen sie wie lange kann das noch
dauern bis wir ein wenig gewissheit
haben es ist wirklich schwierig zu sagen
das ist sehr schwierig zu sagen der
längste fall der den eine suche gedauert
hat in der vergangenheit waren zehn tage
die haben wir jetzt schon längst
überschritten und es wird immer
schwieriger und ob wir letztendlich
tatsächlich einmal erfahren dass da
wirklich passiert ist
also abwarten ich bin mir nicht mehr so
sicher
er wird von tag zu tag die hoffnung
geringer die menschen auch leben noch zu
finden
das denke ich und das wird den
angehörigen auch schmerzhaft bewusst und
deswegen fordern sie ja mit recht auch
informationen tatsächlich anderen
an dieser stelle ein und dass das was
wichtig ist für menschen die eben jemand
verloren haben zum beispiel durch ein
unglück ist dass sie irgendwann auch ein
ort bekommen von dem sie sich von den
menschen auch verabschieden können und
wenn sie tatsächlich vermissen bleiben
weil das flugzeug zum beispiel nicht
gefunden wird dann macht es die
trauerarbeit die aufnahme des
trauerprozesses hinterher viel viel
schwerer es dann schwierig damit
umzugehen was können sie dann noch tun
da sind dann wahrscheinlich auch die
hände gebunden begleiten wegen wir
können sie begleiten dann an dieser
stelle würden vielleicht eine
angehörigengruppe gründen um sie einfach
über die jahre hinweg durch ihre
prozesse zu begleiten
ich danke ihnen recht herzlich dass sie
hier waren in der phoenix runde wer war
haben viele fragen gestellt einige
kleine beantwortet neue sind vielleicht
entstanden ist tatsächlich schwierig zu
spekulieren zu überlegen was passiert
sein könnte wir begleiten diesen fall
die verschwundene maschine weiter hier
bei phoenix auch in den nachrichten
ihnen herzlichen dank fürs zuschauen ihr
interesse und wir sehen uns morgen abend
wieder phoenix 22.15 dann blicken wir
noch einmal in die ukraine einen guten
abend bis dahin tschüss